after seven years of seeing this
photograph and the most damaging
allegations haunting the royal family
virginia dufrese and prince andrew have
unexpectedly reached an agreement
a joint letter from both their legal
teams confirmed the settlement the sum
of which is not being disclosed but
confirming that a substantial donation
will go to mischief race charity that
helps victims that prince andrew accepts
that she has suffered and that he
regrets his friendship with jeffrey
epstein
i think this is the exact right time
where you would expect prince andrew to
have reached the settlement in the case
this is one of those key junctures in a
civil case especially in one like this
where the allegations are so salacious
virginia dufrese claimed that prince
andrews sexually assaulted her on three
occasions when she was only 17. he knows
what he's done and he can attest to that
so can you repeat that
he knows exactly what he's done and
i hope he comes clean about it
last summer she submitted her case for
compensation and new york judge louis
kaplan gave her permission to take it to
trial those representing other victims
believe she deserves recognition for
what she's done
we don't have an admission of liability
here and i know that is disappointing
for people but i strongly support
virginia's decision to make the choice
that's right for her and to end this now
so that she can focus on her charity and
her work
i can see that the royal family has
distanced themselves from him and this
story um and all his um you know his
official duties have now been taken away
i don't think this is going to be
anywhere near any recovery for prince
andrew um because he'll be dogged by
this story for the rest of his life
it's believed this was prince andrew
arriving back at windsor after months of
tense legal discussion both sides have
fallen silent for now the details of
their settlement will remain strictly
between them